alors oui tu as 24 ans tu vis à tour oui
en ce moment et est ton parcours tu vas
tu vas nous l'expliquer parce que tu es
sorti du système scolaire scolaire à
l'âge de 16 ans ouais tu a enchaîné les
petits boulots et là ça fait un an que
tu galères beaucoup plus que ce qui
était arrivé précédemment est ce que tu
peux nous dire déjà pourquoi à 16 ans tu
t'es dit le lycée j'arrête c'est pas
pour moi en fait je me retrouvais pas du
tout non système scolaire le déjà tout
ce qui est théorique c'est ça toujours
été compliqué pour moi je préférais la
pratique j'étais beaucoup plus à l'aise
dans les matières où je pouvais utiliser
où je peux utiliser même un ou alors
quand je sentais que ça m'apportait
quelque chose directement et en plus
pour moi ça se passait très très mal
avec les autres élèves c'était très très
compliqué j'étais très en décalage avec
les gens de mon âge j'ai eu une année
d'un scellement corse est donc déjà
abondante que ça m'a calmé après je suis
allé au lycée et je me suis dit que bas
comme je connaissais beaucoup moins de
gens sales et être plus cool et en fait
j'ai vu aucune différence avec le
collège fin je voyais vraiment pas
l'intérêt d'y aller du coup j'ai attendu
quand même saison et de faire une
deuxième seconde occasion parce que bon
il faut quand même rien lâcher je me
suis dit on va quand même essayer
jusqu'au bout mais ça n'a pas trop
marché et du coup en fait je suis parti
pour travailler directement trouver des
petits boulots parce que ça me
correspondait beaucoup plus est à 16 ans
sans diplôme donc avec en même temps
motivation est ta détermination qu'est
ce qu'on trouve comme petits boulots il
y avait un peu tout souvent c'est des
petits boulots d'une ou deux heures ça a
été beaucoup de baby sitting dans un
premier temps bien sûr elle faisait
aussi beaucoup les courses pour les
personnes âgées moi j'aimais bien enfin
c'était du contact quoi c'était super
cool je faisais aussi des promenades des
chiens et aussi j'ai fait quelques
petits boulots dans la grande
distribution mais c'était compliqué
parce que comme je n'étais pas encore
majeur il y avait beaucoup de choses que
je pouvais pas faire par exemple être en
caisse et c'est donc c'était un peu plus
de riom et puis après ça c'était du coup
quand j'étais à nantes et après je suis
arrivé à tours en fait avec le co vide
en même temps j'ai travaillé six mois en
tant que test de caisse au super u pas
loin de chez moi c'est sa tête est
arrivé à tours avec ton copain début
2000 vendent ou après avoir enchaîné des
le lord ok ça style en mars voilà hockey
et
et en fait après ces six mois je pensais
que je retrouverai un travail très
facilement même pas exceptionnel parce
que j'avais jamais eu trop de
difficultés aux pour ça ça se faisait
bien mais en fait comme je recherchais
beaucoup de boulot dans l'accueil la
réception le contact etc en fait tous
les étés missions dans lesquelles
j'avais postulé ils ont tous fermé bien
sûr pendant le coc vide et au moment où
du coup ça a commencé à rouvrir ce dès
qu'on finit etc toutes les offres en
fait que j'avais été perdus et en plus
plus personne ne voulait lâcher son
travail parce que c'était carrément
devenu quelque chose nous a vraiment
extrêmement précieux oui c'est ça la
norme et mende mal à retrouver ouais et
est en fait derrière j'ai jamais réussi
à retrouver de travail malgré les
journées entières sur pôle emploi les
lettres de motivation les je sais pas
combien d'entretien j'ai fait ça là ça
t1 en vraiment que tu cherche du travail
bref il n'y arrive pas donc
financièrement je suppose que c'est en
ce moment un peu compliqué ah ben c'est
la galère en fait là du coup jusqu'à
demain jusqu'à maintenant veut pas il ya
peu de temps je touchais le chômage ça
allait j'arrivais à me débrouiller tout
ça mais là du coup le mois dernier j'ai
arrêté de le toucher et du coup c'est
très compliqué pour moi parce que je
suis plus du tout indépendante
je suis limite en train de vivre aux
crochets de mon copain et c'est enfin si
c'est difficile en fait un quotidien
coiffe un jeu moi je n'envisage pas du
tout ma vie comme ça et en plus je suis
plein de motivation donc c'est hyper
rageant de se dire mais je demande que
ça de travailler d'être dans le contact
parce que je sais que j'ai des choses à
apporter mais on ne donne pas
l'opportunité et comment ça se passe les
les lettres de motivation que tu envoies
les cv que tu envoies c'est sans réponse
aux réponses négatives du goût les trois
quarts du temps c'est sans réponse ah
ouais donc déjà quand une réponse est
vite et je me dis ils ont répondu oui
déjà c'est sûr ça les remercie de
m'avoir répondu est d'accord que ça et
en fait j'ai eu pas mal de réponses de
gens qui disaient qu'ils étaient très
intéressés par mon cv mais qu'en fait
financièrement depuis qu vite pour eux
c'était très compliqué et qu'en fait ils
étaient en train de licencier et que du
coup il beaucoup d'entre eux bien sombre
quoique sont retrouvés dans ces cas là
et beaucoup de réponses comme ça pour
les restaurants aussi où c'est compliqué
il y en a beaucoup qui ont fermé et et
voilà enfin eu ni à plein de faut que je
paye de réponse du tout en fait et ce
soir sur ce plateau en direct et est ce
que tu as un message à faire passer
justement aux recruteurs au aux patrons
sur sur ton cas personnel mais mais mais
pour aussi tous les gens qui nous
regardent prenez moi
[Rires]
je sais que des fois je peux comprendre
aussi qu'au patron ça fasse peur parce
que j'ai pas j'ai pas une grosse
expérience j'ai pas de diplôme du tout
donc je peux tout à fait comprendre que
ça fasse peur mais vraiment enfin je
connais énormément de gens qui n'ont pas
de diplôme et ils sont aussi
intelligents que les autres y'a pas de
problème les a faits pour le système
scolaire sa dépouille est aussi aidée
foi peut y avoir des choses et la vie
qui font que bah ça passe pas qu'une
année d'étude va être raté alors que les
capacités elles sont là enfin voilà
exactement est vraiment enfin moi je
sais que je suis totalement capables
d'apprendre gelé très bien vu à chaque
fois que j'ai fait un nouveau boulot je
sais très bien ce que je veux quoi
vraiment l'air très capable compétentes
et motivées et donc là dans l'idéal
tonton secteur de recherche privilégiés
ctu vous a dit le contact avec les gens
ouais ouais particulièrement tout ce qui
est accueille contact avec le client
conseil met vraiment en fait moi ce que
je recherche moi c'est du contact humain
je n'ai plus envie en fait de faire des
boulots ou pour moi ça plus de sens
quand je rentre le soir en fait je sais
même pas trop pourquoi je fais ça facile
pour manger enfin voilà quoi y'a un
moment où bon maintenant j'ai 24 ans et
j'ai envie d'avoir un travail où je
m'épanouis bien sûr personnellement et
professionnellement en fait merci
beaucoup
et
très clair je pense que représente une
partie de la population justement comme
tu l'as dit sans diplôme mais
extrêmement compétents capables
autodidacte même un petit peu et que ça
résonne chez beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs ton témoignage a
également résonner très particulièrement
chez la personne que je vais te
présenter immédiatement et qui va nous
rejoindre sur le plateau il s'agit de
mode ben ali
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
qui est directrice général europe du sud
du groupe accor si j'ai bien saisi le
titre dans sa globalité merci beaucoup
mode est sur ce plateau merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de rencontrer
zoé alors ton parcours à toi aussi est
assez est assez fou je vais je vais vous
laisser expliqué à zoé ce que vous
pouvez lui proposer et je pense que ça
peut lui corresponde parfaitement salut
zoé salut alors on se connaît pas encore
où ils savaient pas ce matin mais en
fait je suis là mentor de zoé voilà
pas de chance
moi je crois beaucoup à deux choses
merci agathe de m'avoir invité 1 je
crois qu'il faut traduire les mots en
actes et en fait le groupe accor qui est
un groupe hôtelier le premier groupe
hôtelier en france si je peux me
permettre de le préciser en europe notre
métier c'est l'accueil chez les gens
c'est le conseil et c'est enfin voila
c'est prendre soin des gens c'est
l'hôtellerie en l hospitalité donc dans
le cadre du colis dont on a souffert de
la crise comme beaucoup de secteurs mais
on a été résilient et aujourd'hui
l'activité repart et en juillet on a
signé une tribune avec le gouvernement
le haut commissaire à l'emploi qui
s'appelle un jeune amant tort mais moi
j'aime bien faire suivre les mots
d'actes et donc je suis là aujourd'hui
zoé pour toi parce qu'on va traduire en
acte avec mon co dire sur toute l'europe
du sud la démarche parce qu'on pense que
photo d un coup de pouce aux jeunes que
c'est galère aujourd'hui trouver un job
qu'on a eu de la chance nous et qu'il
faut qu'on rende et à chaque fois qu'on
aura la possibilité d'aider ben voilà on
le fera et c'est un engagement hyper
fort du groupe i et moi à titre plus
personnel donc je vais t'aider
merci deuxio je crois pas à la fatalité
et je sens beaucoup d'énergie de gnac de
courage voilà on sent que ça a été
parfois dur mais je crois beaucoup au
fait qu'on est tous des résignant
consorts peut-être plus fort je vois
beaucoup de qualités que tu as pour
l'hôtellerie l'hôtellerie c'est un
métier de coeur c'est un métier de
passion il faut aimer les gens faut les
surprendre ou quinze jours se
ressemblent et surtour à ou tué depuis
nantes on a une quinzaine d'hôtels j'ai
déjà parlé à certains propriétaires et
certains directeurs d'hôtel seront ravis
d'écouter et moi je serai là à tes côtés
pour te dire voilà ce qui me semble le
mieux pour toi et je serai là en soutien
bienveillant c'est si on pouvait juste
faire chacun tous à notre petit niveau
ça s'appelait devenir viral l'absence de
voilà ça
ça ferait du bien à aussi à notre beau
pays quoi donc je suis ravi
pour résumer ce qui vient de se passer
sur ce plateau et qui m'émeut
particulièrement zoé potentiellement à
tour il y à des hôtels du groupe accor
qui seront ravis de rencontrer de faire
passer des entretiens et potentiellement
de temps bauchet dans ces prochaines
semaines teutons comment comment tu vis
ce moment je peux pas parler à ta place
merci
[Rires]
en fait merci surtout à des personnes
comme vous d'exister parce qu'il est
certain qu'il y en a pas assez et je
suis super contente et je vais vraiment
essayer de profiter à 1000% cette
opportunité et tu vas tout cas c'est tu
vas devenir un des meilleurs éléments
des hôtels d'un tour évidemment qui
j'espère qu'on va exactement à temps
je peux t'assurer que le jour de ton
embauche je viens passer une nuit
week-end
et là la production et mon équipe qui a
travaillé sur la préparation de cette
émission ont retenu aussi un élément de
ton profil qui les a interpellés et qui
très vrai c'est que tu es jeune
effectivement sans diplôme et aussi sans
permis et que c'est très compliqué quand
en plus on n'est pas les culés motorisée
de d'attirer l'oeil des recruteurs donc
sachent que notre production un
partenariat avec pony car kit offre le
permis de conduire et qui va fermer
c'est que ça quand on sait que ça coûte
très cher on sait que tu avais déjà
commencé à prendre des leçons de
conduite et que tu avais déjà entamé le
processus et en icare est profondément
engagé pour la mobilité pour tous donc
si tu peux en profiter ce sera avec
grand plaisir si beaucoup
[Applaudissements]